here's more on some of the Great Moments
of Chuck Todd's tenure over at Meet the
Press you may remember this one Ron
Johnson senator from Wisconsin uh when
he smacked him down over the hunter
Biden laptop Fiasco or non-fiasco
depending on which way you look at it
Chuck is it a crime to be soliciting and
purchasing uh prostitution in
potentially European sex trafficking
operations is that a crime because Chuck
grass and I laid out about thirty
thousand dollars uh paid by Hunter Biden
to those types of individuals over
December 2018 2019 about thirty thousand
dollars this is about the same time that
President Biden offered to pay about a
hundred thousand dollars and 100 Biden's
bills I mean again that's that's just
some information I don't know exactly
it doesn't doesn't really look on the it
sounds sleazy as you know I'll take care
I'll take out your word that you're
ethically bothered by Hunter Biden I'm
curious though you seem to have you not
uh
carrying water for the Democrats I mean
you see that you see what he was doing
right there Ron Johnson is excellent
he's really uh you know having sat down
with him you know you meet some of these
politicians and they're like a little
neither here nor there or sometimes
they're a little weird when looking at
you something like that this guy is like
a freaking laser he's like basically
dude dude he's paying off prostitutes
International prostitutes at the same
time that we know uh his dad Joe Biden
is lending him all this money could you
think there's something there maybe
Chuck Todd awful
[Music]
oh